紹介ありがとうございましたこの場で話ができるということ誠に光栄に思っております
大竹ございます東工大の機械物理工学というところで教授をさせてもらってます
よっ
エンジニアリングを言うかける3これ私にとってのエンジニアリング=いうグロス3
これをカーボンを題材にして今日はお話しを申し上げたいなというふうに思っているん
です
そして同時にせっかくここお若い方がお集まりになっていて
でおそらくビデオでも配信されていると思います
若い方にこうしたら新しい技術って生まれるんだよ
そんなことを一つ分かっていただけるといいのかなこうしたら企業ができるかもしれ
ない
そんな気持ちになっていただけるとすごく幸せだなというふうに思っておりますしそれ
に向けてこの
いう健身を説明していきたいこんな風に思っているんです
最初にお見せするのは全然違う話なんですけれども
ミシガンスタジアムですねアメフトをなさっている方はよくご存じだと思いますとても
大きなスタジアムのでございます
私が立っているのはアメフトをやる部ラウンドでございますね
緑色のところわかっていただけると思います
ここは一番低いところですけれどもこのスタジアムは数万人収容するのでスタジアムの
一番てっぺんのところっていうのは数十メーター
このグランドより高いところにあるんですよね
ここに斑点が降ったとしましょう連業務です
この緑色のところにグランドに落ちた目はそのまま安定ですよね
あちなみにここで排水なんて考えるくださいねごめんなさいはいすい考えられてすごく
多いです
けども
グランドの雨はそのままたまるだろうこれ落ち着いてるんですね
ほら安定な上でって言いますみなさん今の椅子にお世話になっているのは安定な状態
です
それに対してスタジアムの一番上の姉とガスも困るんですねこれ不安定なんですよ
どうしても下に転がりたくなります
人間もそうですよねあそこにいたらやっぱり何かあったりしたら怒っちゃう
私もステージから怒っちゃっていう卵ですねここ若干不安定な状態ですねこれをまず
覚えていただくと徒の話につながるんですね
最初にご紹介したい炭素材料はダイヤモンドでございます
これ203からとあるミレニウムスターっていう宝石なんですけれども今地球上で一番
美しい宝石というふうに言われているんですね
先ほどの作の村の時計とどっちが高いか
ああなり衣装がと思うんですけど
そして私は池上先生だったら旅行を変えるんじゃないのかなという
さっきよっぽど作ろうと思ったんですよ
買ってここで見たようだな you
これ美しいですよね本当に純粋な透明なものですけれども
もう一つカーボンの代表材料とあるんですよね
皆さん
こんなときに使ってないですか
うちの学生に登場しになってますけどバーベキューですね
バーベキューの時に炭で焼くと惜しいですよね
これうまいですねでもダイヤモンドが住みじゃないですよね
普通のゾンビですはい
この炭も実は炭素でできてるんですよね
予報ともこれ炭素でできている
ダイヤモンドの指輪今お持ちの方いらっしゃるかもしれません
罪も c ですカーボンでできてるんですよね
さて
この2つを紹介したところで最初のミシガンスタジアムを思い出してください
この2つを見朱蘭スタジアムに置くとするとどういう大き形になるのか
答えはこうなるんですね
ダイヤモンドはスタジアムのてっぺんなんです
そしてブランドのところには炭があるんですねん
つまりダイヤモンドは不安定な状態で本当だったら
雨粒と同じように下に転がってって
ですみになるはずなんですよ自然界の理は染まっているんです
隅の方安定なんです
今この会場の中にもダイヤモンドの指輪をしてらっしゃる方がいらっしゃるかもしれ
ません
さっきみなみさんチェックしたんですけど残念ながらしてませんでした
で
この指は見てるうちに住みに変わったらもうすごいショックじゃないですか
けれども残念ながらそういう経験をした方っていうのは日本にも世界にも絶対
いらっしゃらないはずなんですね
じゃあオタクに言ってること違うじゃないか
下に落ちるはずなんだろう
ということなんですけれども
それはどうして落ちないのかっていうのは理由があるんです
ここにペットボトルがありますね
これでその理由を説明したいと思うんですちょっとだけ時間ください
今これは炭素材です
俺は隅になろうかな
それでもダイヤモンドになろうかな悩んでます
すみっ
納期方
つまり安定の方をするとすると
こんな格好になりません
皆さんいつもこうやっておきますよね
これ実は安定じゃないです
これが
1番手の置き方なんですね
倒れたらございますよねこれ以上安定な状況じゃないですねこれがブランド state
です
じゃあダイヤモンドあ
平行であることを祈ってよかっ
そうですねこんな状態なんですよ明らかに不安定なんですけれども
何かが起きない限りはコレアスペックが来たら困りますけれども
倒れないんですよねこれ大モードの状態皆さんの指はこの状態なんです
ですのでもし何か外から衝撃が加わるとあるいはエネルギーが加わるとこいつは横に
遭われてしまいますよね
住めになります
たまに報道であるのがダイヤモンドが火事で燃えちゃいました
そんな話がありますねそうですダイヤモンドはこの状態なのでそこで火事で炎に炙ら
れるとエネルギーが加えられて黒煙の争点者を装填って言います
でこれが一度想定してしまってグラファイトになったこれは住みなんですよ
思えちゃうんですね
だからさっきバーベキュー大門でできるかこれできます
できます
ここで行ってみたいですよね
ぜひ今度 web x ぜひお願いしますダイヤモンドバーベキューやりましょう
メスですので絵馬安心していただきたいのはこの状態なので皆さんのダイヤモンドが
変わりませんよということですよね
さあこのダイヤモンド鳥栖に両方を紹介したところで材料の話を少しさせてください
elc と呼んでいますダイヤモンドライクカーボンを呼びますけれども
単純に申し上げると今ご紹介したダイヤモンドが5割
あこっちのして話題持って言ってるわけじゃないですよこっちがスミッツと起こりませ
ん
ダイヤモンドが5割そして炭が5 y
こんな交わった材料のです
ご存知の通りダイヤモンドは地球上で一番硬い材料ですからこれはもう全然削れないん
ですよね
炭はとても滑りやすいツルツル滑ってくれる材料です
ですのでこの2つを組み合わせることによってとってもいいことが起きますね
表面がツルツル滑って削れないこれは環境問題にも良さそうですよね
ですので今この dlc っていうのを一体となって動く応用するのか
これは皆さん一生懸命やってます
私の場合には桜乃さんと違っていて一人ではとても出来ないんですよね
これをアイディアで色のためになる人のためになるような人に使ってもらえるような
ものをこの dlc を使って作るこれは私一人ありがとうおそらく大学でできること
ではないと思うんですよね
私が助けてもらったあるいは一緒にあったのはやはり
東工大の近くにする大田区
この位置はせたバイブですかねあるいは
食事しないですか
どこ代の半分は大田区にあるんですよね
で大田区の中小企業群っていうのは世界に冠たる
中小企業がございますので
ことを連携してこの dlc というようなこのために行かせないのか
そんな話を東光園を経営ローっていますがあってこのロジェーデリアディゾンオフィス
それから大田区の産業振興協会の協力も得てですね話を進めました
でこの中で実はを十数回
あのディスカッションをする機会があったんですよね
大田区から出て来てくださった方は中小企業の本当の親父さんという方はですが
6種なるのか誰です以上に厳しい方ですでその中でまあいろいろ言われながらですね
美術を育ていったということです
私が幸せだったのは何かというとその中でおそらく私の技術に折れてくれた人がいた
こと
私に惚れてくれたらもっと良かったんですけど
技術に惚れてくれるっていうこれもうれしいことですよね
1人
の方を紹介すると
左の松尾実さんですね
この方は創業70数年投稿あの大田区の中でまさに
中心的に
まあマネジメントができた方です3代目の社長さんがいらっしゃったんですけれども
この技術に触れてくれた本当はのウェディングって言ってあの溶接のプロだったんです
ね
dlc と全然関係なかったですこの方にまあ新しい事業を立ち上げるといういかに
難しいのか
そしてまあいかにあのまあこうやったらうまくいくんだというとこ
が教えてもらいました
もうひと方は山本さんや元失うなんですこの方は東工大の産学連携を作った方の
システムをつくった方ですけれども
大竹こんなことじゃあまあなんですかね
知的財産っていうのは守れないよ
やっぱり特許戦略ているんですよね新しいことを立ち上げると聞いてなぁ
それを教えてもらったそんな方ですちょうど今日お二人いらっしゃるのでその場で私に
なって頂けよろしいですか
お二人に教えていただいたことをこれは異なる文化のでいいかなというふうに思って
いるんです
一つはいま申し上げたお宅の中小企業分と東工大これは近くて遠い関係と言われてたん
ですけどそれを水にあったということが一つでもう一つは製造現場度
先端化の技術この融合というの意外と難しくて先端科学技術っていうのはこのまま
たまに成功するといいなっていう場合もあるんですよ正直ましたけれどけど
を製造現場っては失敗ちゃいけないですよね
そこの関係っていうのはクロスしてはすごく重要かな
もう一つ人間関係としては
百戦錬磨んの方
と自分のことですけども研究一筋
僕もお酒も飲んだりするので一つ時間もうちょっとわかりませんけども一応ここでは1
数字で言わせてください
この関係もとても重要かなそんなクロスがあって新しい持って生まれるんだなぁって今
になっては思っているんです
そこから生まれたどこ大発ベンチャー先ほど紹介いただきましたけれども
マーキー技術は右上にありますねセグメント構造 dlc といってさっき言った
ダイヤモンドと炭の合いの子っていうのをタイル状に貼ったもので子の設計によって
非常に耐摩耗性に優れた
削れにくい剤
8を作ることができますで左上のその合成装置とかあるいは
左下の
自動車部品ですねこんなことを開発して最後にお乗り優位美容用あのうまー
髪の毛を切る浅めですねこれを開発しました
でここに自動車を持って来るわけにはいかないのでこのハサミでですね
やっぱり性能いいねというところを見ていただけるといいかなとあるいは生のあまり
変わらないということもありえるんですけども
このコーティングをすることによって切れ味がどう違うかって言うのを実現したいと
思ってちょっとこちらの方この顔を強くないですか
と思いますこれ実際に切ってもらういうふうに思うんですよ
どんなに切ってもらったらいいかなと思って悩んでるんですけども
あのー池上先生に来てもらったらどうかということで皆さんよろしいですかねぇ
これが普通のハサミですね
どうしましょうかこの俺で会余興はいこれチャットざくざくっと彼女だと思って来て
ください
強いながらそのなんですこれ着るわけですねそうですねちょっと切れ味を先生覚えて
おいていただいてございましたはいすいません
じゃあこの変更勝っていいですかそいつね
はい
こうやってきたはいわかりましたずいぶんきましたねいいね
ro ハイザックザクザクって解析してこれが開発したものです
はい
じゃあ行きますよはいっ
えええええっを一緒にしてくれたんです
ちゃいましたというこれねまた新製品のでしょ
はいいい安心セクシー動画いいって言わなきゃいけないでしょ
するでしょ
なんて思って切れ味が違ったらどうしようと思ってやってやな
を負かそうかと思ってたんですけど日本で最初のやつはザックザックザックとやって
切れた
はいけないとのはすっとと思っていっぺんに綺麗
はい確かにこちらの方が綺麗にするの予想です
ございますよね
それではまだウィッグがそのままですけれども最後のまとめをさせていただきたいなと
思います
最後にいうテクノロジーこれが道一つの式であらわされるかそんなことを考えてみます
と
まずは技術のシーズだろうこれ間違いないですよね
でそれを先ほど申し上げました仲間がいることが大切ですそして仲間との情熱
ファッションですねこれとの掛け合わせで育てていくこれはどうしても必要なんです
けど
もそこで一番最後に申し上げたいことこれは寛容であること
これです
人が違う意見が違うこれが大切なんだよと言っているということは必ず自分と違うん
ですよね
意見が違う立場も違うもしかしたら利益4判かもしれないです
けれどもその相手を認めるお互いに寛容になる
これが新しい技術を甘い一番大事なことだと私は思います
ぜひ若い方におかれてはちゃんと勉強して技術の種をまず幕
これは役目ですそれから仲間を作る
そして仲間と情熱を共有する
まさにエディックスそうですよねこれ大事ですそしてお互いの寛容性
これをもって新しい技術を産んでいただければ幸いだなということで私の話を結びたい
と思いますどうもありがとうございました